咱们今天呢讲这个片子是让子弹飞。为什么讲这个片子呢？因为确实啊首先啊这个片子呃很多同学如果问过我，让我拉一下这个片子。
这个片子的类型呀、结构呀、角色分布呀，问这样一些问题。
第二个呢是因为这个嗯子弹飞啊，咱们因为咱们的课程啊，以前都是在B站上，对吧？子弹飞啊在B站上有他。
呃，这个独特的一定的江湖地位啊，所以很多同学啊特别喜欢解读这个片子。
啊，呃有同学说之前的拉片没看过，没关系啊没关系，那从今天开始。
从今天开始。
咱们正式开始上课啊。
呃，由于是这个付费直播，咱就不哈拉了啊。进来晚了的同学，咱咱就不不等他了。
1块钱也是钱呀，对吧？
咱们正式开始拉片让子弹飞。首先说一下拉片的意。
咱们这个编剧也好，导演也好，凡是搞创作的啊，都要经常拉片啊，反复看一部片子，然后分析人家片子的结构。特别是我们编剧啊，我们编剧拉片啊，你一定要搞清楚我们编剧拉片的目标是什么。我们编剧的拉片啊，首先得看人家的创作一个整个的一个心路过程。你得知道他这个片子是怎么写出来的。
甚至你能看出他是怎么改出来。
然后今天拉这个让子弹飞呢，那我我们还有一点优势啊，就是我其实呃是比较了解这部电影它的创作过程啊，所以呢呃呃可以尝试跟大家分享一下啊。因为他们之前这几个编剧啊，我认识其中几个啊。
然后呢嗯但是咱们既然说到让子弹飞啊，我也知道这个。
很多同学啊很多同学这个所谓的有个叫什么让学还是什么是叫让学吧，就专门研究让子弹飞啊，专门解读里面呢。
各种各种解解读里面的暗喻啊。首先啊看片子啊不要做过度的解读啊，这个首先要搞清楚啊，那所谓你所谓的暗喻呀，什么马拉的列车呀，然后又往。
左走往右走呀，这些事情啊尽量不要去过度解读啊，咱们主要去看一些什么，从他们编剧角度。
从他们编辑角度就是。
主要是学一个片子的创作思路。
来，今天先哎，咱们先先说一下啊。
咱们先来研究一下一个事情啊，来同学们啊愿意打字的话啊，咱们先来研究一下，你们都看了让子弹飞，大家给我提炼一下让子弹飞的一句话故事。
给我提炼一下让子弹飞的一句话故事。
有没有同学能说一下，让子弹会回忆一下，让呃回忆一下什么叫一句话故事啊，什么叫一个故事的故事创意。
什么人？
在什么情况下他想干。
对不对？
一个什么样的人？
遇到一个什么样的情况，他想要干什么？
回忆一下这个啊一句话故事。
然后。
同学们。
每个人想一下你对让子弹飞的回忆，你心里先想一个一句话故事。
然后待会儿咱们再统一的探讨一下。
好不好？咱们先进入剧情。
咱们先进入剧情好吧？好，咱们正式开始上课。
第一部分内容先给大家讲一下让子弹飞的信息包。什么叫信息包啊？同学们回忆一下，来记得信息包的同学给我扣个一啦。记得什么是信息包的同学给我扣个一。我给大家讲一下什么是信息包啊。
信息包就是一个电影啊，它传达出来的信息啊传达出来的信息。有的时候一个信息包是一场戏，有的时候一个信息包是好几场戏啊，是好几场戏。
先来给大家讲一下啊，让子弹飞的信息。
有条件的同学可以开始记笔记了啊。我提醒一下，有条件的同学可以开开始记笔记了，记完笔记你回头可以自己再看一遍啊。
回头再自己再对，也叫信息节拍啊。有条件的同学可以开始记笔记了。
我要开始说了啊。
让子弹飞。
的信息节拍啊，大家开始记笔记。
第一排。
第一拍啊，一伙马匪。
鞋嘛。
县长上任的列车。
啊，而且还点了一下题，让子弹再飞一会儿。我们来这个现场的列车啊，马拉的一个列车在飞驰，然后然后啊这个这个。
一个马匪把这个。
把这个列车给截了啊，让子弹再飞一会儿。
这是第一个信息包啊，4分钟4分钟。
然后4分钟之后进你签名。
4分钟之后进片名啊，进这个绕子弹飞的片名。
进天名之后，第一场第一个包是什么呢？张麻子审问县长啊，审问这个呃这个这个葛优这个角色。然后葛优呢就假冒自己是师爷。
然后呢，张麻子听说了。
当县长可以搞钱，这些件事情决定假冒县长搞钱。好吧，第二个信息包啊，决定假冒现场搞钱。
第三个包。
县长的欢迎仪式啊县长的欢迎仪式。
这个有这个。
而且这个县城门口啊有这个马匪的通缉力啊，然后黄四郎呢派来了两个人来送礼帽啊，他两个手下啊来送礼帽。黄四郎呢自己在暗中观察啊，这是一个反派登场的戏。也就是说主角到达主场景，然后反派立刻登场啊，而且反派登场的时候呢。
由于同学们啊大家记住啊，电影一个信息包啊，一场戏往往包含很多很多因元素，包含很多信息。所以说它的信息比较密集，特别是第一幕啊。我们说是一个电影的第一幕信息比较密集。大家记一下啊。
我们说在县长的这个欢迎仪式上，我们展现了马匪的通缉力，展现了黄四郎派了两个人来送礼帽。
这两个人来送礼貌显然很不礼貌，对吧？然后黄四郎呢自己在暗中观察，这是一个反派登场啊，反派登场的过程，顺便把训练替身埋了一个伏笔啊，把训练替身这件事情又埋了一个伏笔。
然后呢，我然后我们这个反派啊，黄四郎在暗中观察的时候，发现了这个县长啊进城就开枪霸气外露啊，这是第三个信息包啊，这是第三个信息包。在一场戏当中啊，在一个大厂当中就完成了啊第三个信息包。
有同学说了，在这之前还有路上葛优逃跑的戏啊，我们说那种戏啊不算信息胞啊。
第四包。
第四个信息节拍啊。
就是。
起始目标。
有阻力了，我们说它的起始目标是什么？这个县长本身的起始目标是要搞钱啊，发现第一个阻力就是穷人已经没有钱了啊，收税收不到了啊，收税已经收到若干年以后了。
然后呢，师也。
说出了搞钱的方法，张麻子不同意。
说要站着挣钱啊，这是第四个。
张麻子说要站着把先胜。
第五个节拍，渊古事件。
这个小六子啊小六子啊把这个远古给扯出来了，远古扯出来之后呢，卖粉儿的卖两粉的那个家伙呢，被这个股吓着了，撞了武状元。然后武状元呢就欺负卖粉的这个家伙，然后张麻子就把武状元给揍了。
立威，而且喊出了自己的口号，我追求三件事情，公平公平公平，这是第五个节拍。
第六个节拍啊。
第六个节拍小六子小六子跟着张麻子一起听过扎特。
这个节拍这个很短，但是为为什么单独是一个节拍呢？因为埋了一个伏笔，因为埋了一个伏笔，小六子要死了，对吧？第六个节拍啊，小六子跟着张麻子一起停莫扎特，然后聊自己的浏洋梦想，要去东洋，要去西洋，要去南洋，对吧？
聊自己的刘洋梦想，实际上是埋一个伏笔，这家伙要死。
然后马上第七个节拍。
第七个节拍。
黄四郎就威胁那个卖粉的家伙，是吧？
黄四郎利用卖粉的家伙，然后呢向。
主角团队发起第一次正式的进攻。
发起第一次正式的进攻。在第一次正式的进攻当中，黄四郎的手下就把小六子给逼死了啊，小六子给逼死了。
然后在发起进攻的同时啊，这里大家要记住你一号登了一下。
女一号登了一下场啊，女一号那个花姐稍微登了一下场。
然后交代了他是黄四郎的卧底。
然后第七个信息胞主要讲的是黄四郎利用麦粉老，然后呢让陈坤和姜武去把小妹子给逼死了啊，然后扎麻子来营救来迟了。
然后第八个信息胞。
第八个信息胞就是小六子的葬礼，小六子的葬礼在这里小六子的葬礼是什么作用呢？扔出了主线目标报仇。
扔出了A故事的主线目标报酬。大家记一下，第八场扔出的主线目标报酬。
然后。
我们的主角张麻子明确的对着小六子的葬礼，对着小六子的墓碑啊，那个墓碑。
说出了要把黄这个黄四郎连根拔掉啊。
一幕结束到这里是多少分钟啊？
我们看一下这场是多少分钟啊。
待10分钟，我们发誓替你报仇。
把事替你报仇。
可不想让他。
做马飞吗？
不应该听他的，姓唐的不是好玩意儿。
留言。
四郎这招叫杀人不用刀，我给你爹出的招叫杀人诛心，不能拼命了，拼命还怎么挣钱呢？
挣钱对咱算个事儿吗？我不是要杀人诛心，是没想出好办法，我要把黄四郎连根都拔掉。
时间好，大家看一下这场戏。这场戏呢就是第一幕结束了啊，第一幕结束了，目标明确跑出来了。而且抛目标的过程这有个小小的叫什么？
主角团队，我们说主角团队理论上都是主角。
理论上，主角团队都是主角的分身，他们发生了一个什么？
他们内部发生了什么？用我们课上的术语，这叫什么？
来来来，同学给我说一下。
这叫什么？
他们在明确自己的目标之前有个意见不统一，咱们课上管这叫什么？
背后啊术语呢。
术语，咱们的课上的术语。
争执啊，哎呦我的天哪，这沟壑分歧隔阂什么都出来了。争执呀。
确定激励事件激励事件，我们说激励事件把我们激上了，我们要开始确定目标了，确定目标之前是要有争执的。
对不对啊？
确定确立目标之前有争执，所以大家意见不统一，但是主角是谁呀？主角显然是这位张麻子呀，他说要把黄四郎连根拔起，就是报仇。
升值结束啊，有然后这里呢是第32分钟，同学们，我们刨去片头有几分钟啊，片头有4分多啊，4分多5分钟。所以第一步这里打点基本上打在二十七八分钟啊。我们说一部片子这部片子应该是呃。
2个小时吧。
这片子是2小时左右啊，所以第一幕打在了30多分钟啊，第一幕打在了32分钟。
刨掉偏头偏头不算啊，偏头不算的4目里面一定要记住，待会儿我们跟大家详细讲，偏头有5分钟啊，刨出去来进入第二幕。
我们先按照四目式讲啊，当然了，传统电影一般也有按三部写的。我们来按照四幕去。
去看一下啊，来。
第九个信息包继续记笔记啊，继续记笔记。
同学们。
第九个信息包啊进入第二幕。第二幕是谢丽的，相对轻松一点，来到了这个地方啊，轻松一点就要干什么呢？
那就要吃饭喝酒唱歌了啊。来。
第九目呃第第九目了第九个节拍啊，红收到鸿门宴的邀约啊，收到鸿门宴的邀约正式开启。第二幕。张麻子跟汤师爷呢目的不一样，但是都同意要去复宴啊，要去复宴。
这是第九个信息part鸿门医院的邀请来。
然后第十0个信第十0个信息胞呢，就是这场鸿门宴大戏啊，整整持续了十三四分钟啊，一场长达14分钟的鸿门宴大戏。在这场戏里面，当然当然有很多很多的信息啊，首先双方互相先威胁，对吧？然后呢也互相表达了诚意。
对不对？既有威胁也有诚意。然后呢，为了获取对方的信任呢，也坦诚了自己的部分伪装。
我们都知道谈判啊，你跟别人谈判，你既要威胁别人，也要表达诚意。然后呢，也要承认之前我有些地方做的不对，对吧？我有些错误坦诚不自己的部分伪装。比如说那个。
人家师爷就坦称自己啊，其实我知道英文US dollar对吧？我不能假的装装装糊涂。
然后呢，而且还送礼物，这个这个寄这个黄四郎既送上了自己的三条人命啊，虽然是假送，但是送上自己三条人命，也送上了钻石，甚至想送上黛玉晴恩子，对吧？
然后最重要的这场戏是达成了一个新的约定。
达成了一个新的约定，是要干什么？要合作捞钱。
达成的一个合作捞钱的约定。我们说起实目标不就是来鹅城捞钱吗？
马匪主角团队的起始目标就是来鹅城捞钱。所以在这里达成了合作捞钱的约定，一起要灭掉。
所谓的张马子啊，一起要灭掉所谓的张马。
大家记住啊，鸿门宴是。
主角团队跟黄四郎的第一次交锋，我们说你同学们待会儿自己数一下啊，主角团队跟对手的交锋是是起伏状的。
呃，也就是说双方永远各胜一局。在这一局当中，张麻子。
得一分。在这一局当中，张麻子得一分，也就是说第10个信息包红门宴队场啊，张麻子得一得一分。
然后第11个信息包回到住所啊，立刻黄四郎派来的杀手就来干什么杀鸡取卵啊，杀鸡取卵，然后夫人被杀。
夫人被杀以后呢，黄四郎兰赶紧来假装探望这里黄四郎又得一分，黄四郎派人来杀。
县长结果把这个刘嘉玲给误杀了啊这个。
黄四郎。
得一分儿。
然后第12个信息节拍，第12个信息节拍呢夫人的葬礼。
马上来到夫人的葬礼，在夫人葬礼上发生了一个什么事呢？
黄四郎呃，黄张麻子趁机绑架三大家族。
也就是说。
张麻子利用夫人的婚礼，再反攻一手绑架三大家族。
但是。
黄四郎却脱身了。
因为。
黄四郎用的替身。
但是张麻子说这才刚刚开始，对吧？也就是说在这一回合里面，张麻子又先得一分，但是黄四郎又回头又替身又返回一分，所以又是一个回合。
然后。
第13个节拍。
第13个节拍，因为绑架了三大家族当中的两大家族，所以钱到手了。
钱到手了。
钱到手了是什么意思呢？
钱到手了是。
实现了起始目标。
主角团队的起始目标是什么来着？搞钱钱到了。所以在这里咱们之前不是说目标有争执吗？在这里争执重现呀，团队马上开始讨论，钱到手了，咱走吧，对不对？对吧？以那个老三还有汤师爷都说咱钱到手了，咱走吧，起始目标实现了，对吧？
其实目标实现了在这里啊在这里其实目标实现了之后扎麻子。
张麻子变卦了，也就是说我们的主角这个张文老师演的这个张麻子变卦了说。
要把钱发给穷人。
唐诗也非常不理解非常不理解。然后呢。
不理解这是什么招数，这我们这是干啥，对吧？这怎么能收拾得了？
黄四郎呢在这里隐含着一个什么？
我们说这这马上到第二幕结束了，第二目结束叫什么？
同学们，如果四目制的话，第二部结束叫什么叫故事什么来，我看看有没有同学。
虚假的胜利。哎呀，这个同学这这这表扬赶紧表扬。
故事终点啊故事拐点，虚假的胜利。对终点啊说终点的也对，说虚假胜利也对，这些同学都非常优秀。
我们搞到钱了，初始目标实现了，但是主角不满足主角现在要换目标，钱不算什么，钱给我发给穷人啊。
这里张麻子又赢一局，刚才最后刚才上一场替身是黄四郎又赢一分。你看这里张麻子又赢一分，对吧？搞到了钱，把钱发给穷人，张麻子又搞又赢一分。
然后第四第14个信息胞是什么嘞？
14个信息包啊是个小包。
活捉间谍花姐啊活捉女一号，因为这个戏啊女女女女性角色的气份确实太少，女一号就是花姐，所以这里要单独给她一场戏。你把这个花姐抓来了啊，但是放了对对对对方一条生路，因为花姐知道你的秘密了，而且花姐是黄四郎的间谍。
其实扎麻子是知道的啊，扎麻子问他是不是姓黄啊，对吧？其实是知道他是间谍的，但是放了他一条生路啊，奠定了他是女号。
人家是嘉文老师的太太，对吧？必然是。
所以说这个基本位置放在这里，第14个信息包就是单独留给周运的啊。
在这里我们说来这一场戏。
第二部结束。
家看一下啊，第二幕结束这场线捞两遍就能亲眼看见了。嫂子要是不走。
这钱都到不了这桌上，对我老婆的命换了个这些钱，人家小六的命不算命啊，那不一样，怎么他妈就不一样啊。夫人谁夫人王夫人，你夫人怎么了？夫人是被黄四郎杀死的，你们家六爷自残自杀，他们以前帮了你，你敢是我们家小六子真生魂。
你把枪别拿枪对着我，我见过土匪，没见过练块的土匪。
叫什么呀？别笑，别笑，我是说你们家六爷，你们家六爷这样，那是英雄啊，是是是英雄，我老婆嗯睡着觉。
没修我来叔啊，嫂子也是英雄。各位哥哥，咱为什么来了？钱钱到钱到了吗？钱到了。
走啊走啊，那你还哭什么呀？我可以不哭，大哥什么时候走？
先。
不是黄色狼送的。
两大家族的钱不算钱啊，我要的是黄四郎的钱。
你不花穷人的钱，也不要大户的钱子。
熟人。
两条命。
必须黄色龙来查，你这是玩命啊，赌徒。
那就算赌了，算就是还赌不赢。
全不走。
钱也都不要了，花出去。
我是大哥。
这钱你都发给谁了？
发给穷人的。
好，同学们看到啊，这就是故事拐点来了，发给穷人啊，故事正中间。
就是一个小时，正好一个小时027秒啊，故事的正中间故事拐点。第二幕结束。
第二目结束啊。
，这里后面还有一个信息包啊，留给女一的活捉花姐。然后。
然后进到第三步，第三步来了啊，同学们继续记笔记。
同学们继续记笔记第三步来了啊，第15个班是什么嘞？
黄四郎看到你你发钱，你发钱不是赢了一局吗？
见招拆招，让他的人扮成马匪，把钱又抢了回来，顺便还干什么？
顺便还侮辱了民女。
你看这个同学非常优秀啊，说第三步坏蛋来了，太好了，坏蛋之前就出现了。但是在这一幕他要干坏事儿的啊，干很坏的坏事。
路民女。
侮辱民女呢还栽赃给张麻子，所以呢他又将了张麻子一军。
黄四兰又得一分。
然后这是第五个包啊，第15个信息节拍。第16个信息节拍呢发现康师爷一个小秘密啊，单独给了制片人一场戏。这8岁儿子那场戏啊，那场戏呢咱说实话啊属实没有什么用，那场戏啊属实没有什么用啊，但是呢。
哎，我们去看一下啊。
呃，咱们同学们啊，在之前我在拉片的时候啊，同学们啊之前我在拉片的时候，我我经常说这场戏属实没什么用的时候啊，有些同学就反弹啊，有用有用，人家那么牛逼的大师写的能没用吗？我不一定啊不一定是这个这个摆盘，你你就算去最好的饭店啊，你去最好的饭店吃饭。
上来的菜摆盘当中啊，也有东西，它就是为了摆盘而已。所以大家啊也不要太较真儿啊不要太较真儿。有时候这么一场戏啊，就是一个玩乐，就是一个玩笑啊，没有任何你们以为的什么深刻的比喻啊。
8岁的儿子，这是拔标助长呀，比喻当时的什么民国八年，我们中国就是一个巨婴，什么，哎呀，我的空军啊就是。
这一套给解读啊，就说当时这个8岁的孩子长这么高。
这个就是我们当时民国的这个这个这个现状呀，我们当时就是北洋政府，就是一个巨英，他虽然拥有了这个总统总理这么一套内阁，但是呢实际上。
这个这个这并不是一个成年人，什么只是个孩子，这就有很多让学的同学啊愿意做的解读，我不反驳，我也不反对啊。但是从我们编剧的角度，我从我们讲故事的角度啊，我们这个。
就是这个觉得这场戏啊属实没有什么大用啊，来看一下。
长时业的小秘密侮辱民女后面。
听出来了。
你们都个个身怀绝技。
有人骗了我谁呀谁呀？
这么明显的事儿，一个师业看不出来。
这明明是黄四郎老狗日的找人冒充的。
心里一定有鬼。
走出来走起来快起。
你最近。
跟什么人吃过饭？
见过黄鼠狼不许动继续队来退孩子孩子孩子我的。
你是个孩子。
那谁？
这他妈是8岁，没人信，我都不信3岁跟他妈一样高，5岁就跟我一样高，8岁就这样了。。
尼玛尼妈尼妈尼妈。
这是你亲吗？孙我吗？这是你亲爹墨家的事怪你屁事啊，妈。
哎，嫂子怎么回事？那是来要钱的，不给钱，我不走，不给钱不走这个老片子。
8年前在俺三期开矿，骗了钱咱都不说了吧，还骗了我的身子，还不讲信誉。
他欠一狗子账，赔狗子走了，人家问来追账呢，把我6岁的娃给压了，当人质你不给钱就撕票了，不是我的。
揍死你的揍是我的揍死你的死你的，那死的日子了。
啊，骗了人家钱嗯。
啊，就是这场戏啊呃就是这是这就是第16个这个信息节拍啊发现汤师爷的小秘密啊，唐师爷有自己的这个私生子，但是后面没什么用，因为也炸死了啊，后面又炸死了。所以说。
这场戏啊从戏剧结构上啊。
没有什么大用啊没有什么大用。呃，有些同学非得说就是对当时生这个社会一种深刻的比喻啊，我觉得可能姜文老师也没这么想。
老师就是觉得唉这傻小子挺好玩的。
还，这个制片人啊挺好玩的，就去就搞就搞一下他就恶搞。
开心一下啊，当然了，有笑链，有喜剧，你也可以说是那就是有作用了，对吧？我之前课上其实讲过啊，马什梅。
呃，什么呃马马马呃什什么冬梅马冬梅对吧？马什么梅是吧？马东什么那场戏啊也没有什么太大的作用啊，搞搞气氛啊，搞搞气氛。所以说大家不要太在意啊。
但是我们姑且算它是一个信息节拍。
实际上可以略过啊可以跳过。就好像大家有没有发现我在给大家讲信息节拍的时候，我可没讲。
男主角和。
那个县长夫人睡觉的那种。
对不对？
同学们记不记得有那么场场戏啊？
同学们记不记得有那么一场戏呀？
那男主角跟现场夫人睡觉，我给你们找出来。
兄弟罗子凡，大家看一下这场只位劫财。
不得放一下。
清床。
暂不入身。
强在此。
若是兄弟我。
有冒犯夫人的举动。
你可以随时干掉我。
洛者夫人有任何要求。
兄弟我。
也绝不推辞。
对，就是这场戏啊，我压根儿都没给他算一个信息包，为什么？首先这一场戏啊对大戏剧结构啊没有什么作用啊，因为。
确实是再不弄这么一场戏，那个那个人家呃刘嘉玲就就就就就杀青了啊，再不弄这么一场戏，刘刘嘉玲就杀青了，所以说呢也得给人加个一两场戏，否则真的是大老演来一趟，完全就没有戏。因为他身上确实没有扛上任何的故事线啊。
同学们演员挑角色啊，其实看一看剧本，他就知道自己这个角色将来是一个什么状态。
你像这种角色啊，完全没有人物转变，他身上也没有任务，就这个角色他本身没有目标。
这个角色他本身没有目标，然后他在整个故事当中呢，他也没有变化，他甚至也没有对抗，对吧？没有目标，没有对抗，没有变化。那这个角色基本上就是个打酱油的角色。你还有很很多同学可能说，哎呀，那这戏里面一共就这么几个角女性角色，这就算女女主角，或者这就就像女。
完全不是啊完全不是。呃，因为这种角色啊，它就是走个过场啊，走个过场。所以说。
没有那么大的。
这个这个解读空间。所以说刚才我们也没把这个列信息包啊，回来回来回来啊，同学们回来从这场戏给我跳回来啊，讲到刚才第16个信息节拍了啊，给了那个GPM11个出镜啊，然后第七个信息包。
黄四爷把花姐，还有老二老三给堵了。
黄四爷把花姐，还有老二老三给堵了啊。第17个星期节拍的时候，黄四爷把老二老三给堵了啊，在这儿啊。
咱先看一下这场戏。
我我为我调到这里，是为了把你们拉回来啊，是为了把你们拉回来。
黄四爷把花姐，还有老二老三给堵了，黄四爷啊在这里这场戏第一，他发现了花姐不靠谱了啊。第二呢，花姐在这场戏之后也正式站队马匪这一伙了啊，也正是战队马匪这一伙了。所以说这个信息包也比较重要。然后第18个包第18个节拍。
下雨的夜晚再次发钱。
再次发钱，对吧？我们的张妈阿子说接着发接着发。然后呢，这次由于双方都知道对方有所准备了。
对吧你上次也教了我一下，我也知道你今天晚上发钱了。所以这一次双方准备好了的一次正式的火拼。
然后在火拼的过程中呢，黄四郎还夜会了汤师爷啊，宴会了汤师爷。
然后。
但是在这一场当中啊在这一场当中。
在今天晚在这个雨夜决战当中呢，遭麻子获胜了啊招麻子获胜了。
那个呃黄四狼那边的。
呃，人全都干掉了，然后在干掉之后，在这个情况的胁迫下。
黄四郎答应三天之后出钱支援。
主角团队出生交费。
出钱了，这很重要的一个信息啊。
但是答应出钱了之后，这是张麻子赢了一局啊，黄四郎不能闲这样。
第1九拍，黄四郎扶植了一个假张码子，也就是胡军演的那个角色啊。
黄四郎扶植了一个假张码字啊假张码字。
然后。
要出一个奇招，要扎死张麻子啊。
福持假张麻子，要炸死张麻子。
然后团队出现了分裂啊，第20个节拍，团队内部出现了分裂。这里呢二姐走了，但是呢花姐要加入啊，花姐要加入。
花姐要加入团队，二哥呢直接走了啊，这里呢就搞了一个搞出了一个事情啊，搞出了一个事情，为后面呢也埋了一点伏笔啊。
然后张麻子呢安排花姐看替身啊，这个信息比较重要。
他张花姐不是要加入吗？张麻子安排他看替生。
然后21。
21个新息节拍。
21个星期节派发生了一件什么事情啊？这场戏大家着重看一下啊，这场戏大家着重。
黄四郎发现了主角的假身份。
这里待会儿我们要讲一下啊。
来看一下。
了这么多人，他一分钱都不出，今天怎么突然出了这么多钱，你觉得突然。
太突然，我也觉诶。
有的，那到底是怎么回事？我还想知道是怎么回事。
花钱买了个线官，我总得有个证件吧。
到底是怎么回事？我是。
这照片是你吗？
这里看到啊。
呃，哎，你看同学说的非常好啊，身份危机爆发。这个待会儿咱们着重讲啊，身份危机爆发为什么放在这个位置啊？
但是。
但是啊我们说这是第21个。
第21个节拍发现身份危机之后啊，质问张麻子，但是张麻子跟汤师爷呢配合之下化解了过去。
化解了过去之后呢，双方又达成和解，继续推进刚才那个事儿，就是筹钱剿匪的事儿啊，继续推进筹钱剿匪的事。
这身份危机化解的很 easy级啊，迅速就化解了，对吧？你看迅速化解了之后呢，可是他们看觉到麻，谈愣了心里想就为是真话说哎对，正这前玩意就是我想找你等到150，对吧？只要我出钱。
但是呢最终继续落两了，继续推进，继续推进剿匪的事儿。
早已经为你准备好了啊，鹅城到处都是我的钱。
不在这儿。
这只是一半。
我们想挣多少？
必须出多少？三舅有招。
继续推进剿匪的事。
然后第22个节拍钱到位了，正式出征啊，正是这里正式出征钱到位了啊，这里正式出征。
然后。
我们的主角双男主啊，我们的最重要的两个角色男一男二张麻子跟汤师爷互相袒露了心声啊，互相袒露了心声。第二2场给大家看一下啊，第二2拍钱到位了以后，他们上路剿匪。
资伟任叫邦德怎么了？后面中华民国8年8月念过的字，当初紫伟任马邦德为康城县长，哎，等会饿死我康城，不是鹅城吗？从来就是康城，好小子，怨你呀，你把我泡水里。
以酒桶靠脸上，闹钟咔咔咔响，吓死我了，我灵机一动，让你信何尝。这鹅城跟康城有什么不一样？康城富饶，鹅城凶险，那你为什么让我去啊？你牛背。
劫火车，我告诉你啊，你进了鹅城就有两种情况。第一，你进城就被黄四郎弄死，我马走康城从容上任。第二，你有种咱俩办了黄四郎，就像现在这样好，说的好，马王德，你这个骗子，早晚有一天你会被张麻子一枪崩你崩了我。
你舍不得这你还真心。
这里两个人袒露心声有两个原因。第一个原因是上一场啊，相当于张麻子刚刚发现了，他被汤师爷骗了嘛。汤师爷对吧？汤师爷，你你你你告诉我你是师爷，其实你就是县长，对吧？然后呢，在后面呢，然后他又告诉这个这个这个这个叫什么？
呃，汤师爷呢又告诉他，其实也不是鹅城。为什么袒露心生？最重要的一个原因是啥？
最重要的一个原因是啥？就是两个人在这里交底，最重要的原因是啥？
一下一场要死了，对吧？又是要死了又死了啊。
第二3场啊第二3场遭遇伏击，一场火拼。
遭遇伏击，一场火拼啊，一场重要的火拼。然后呢，老二师爷都死了。
包括包括那个那个。
唐世业的老婆儿子是吧？都死了。
第23个星期节拍遭遇一场伏击啊，一场大型的火拼都死了。当然最后张麻子还是赢了，把那个假张麻子啊一枪给崩了。
到这里啊。
死的死逃的逃啊，不是逃逃，都死了啊，都死了。
同学们都知道啊，这就。
到了最黑暗的时候了，对吧？
在这里是多少分钟？
一分呃1小时43分，大家来看一下。
神命吧，快快。
到底是不是？
我可是快要死。
骗过你。
骗了就骗了。
我想。
我死之前。
我必须得告诉。
你说。
我那么说这第二档的事。
那谁。
你还记得吗？
没有。
嘿我会。
哎，呦。
然下一场回合城雄赳赳气昂昂进入一次路。
我弄不清楚。
去现场。
得了钱不逃命。
莫非要跟我鱼死网破？
第四摩啊雄赳赳气昂昂第24场第24个拍啊，不是24场第24拍张麻子回城造势要杀黄四郎，这次非常明确了啊，两人隔空对峙，甚至喊出甚至喊出了时间锁，甚至喊出了康大，我们叫时间倒计时。
他说什么三天给我三天，我要杀黄四郎，但是开始的时候，他的弟兄问他，对吧？咱们四个杀黄四郎有几成把握，他说只有三成，对吧？第24拍啊，雄赳赳枪昂杀回鹅城要杀黄四郎。我们说。
在课上我给大家讲过啊，戏进入第四路要怎么样来着？节奏要螺旋上升，加快了啊。
同学们，我们看第二幕和第三步，实际上啊你也可以理解它就是。
黄四郎跟张麻子，你一下呀，我一下，你打我一下呀，我怼你一下，对吧？你捅步我一下呀，我捅步你一下，像极了什么啊？
像极了我们小时候玩的回合制网游啊，对吧？你扔我一个炮弹，我扔你一个炸弹炸雷是吧？像极了这种回合制网游。
明白这意思吧？
所以说啊。
这个。
你来往往。
但是到了第四幕呢，这个你来我我往啊，它依然是这个状态，但是明显加快速度了啊。大家回忆一下第四幕明显加快速度了，我给大家复盘一下。
第25趴。
招麻子回城之后，第一件事情干嘛？
开始发钱。
第二5拍发钱。
老百姓把钱都拿走了。
而且你看同学说回合制回合制非常明显了。到了第四步，我给大家看一下这个格局啊。
这还不叫回合制啊。
一条街乘的头是一个一方，乘这头是一方，这不就是互相拥炸弹的那个字吗？你扔我一下，我扔你一下吗？
大家看一下这个格局。
一条街花花的选子都散给了穷人，做孽。
你看这不就是回合制吗？
散不了。
大家看一下这是不是回壳制，除了鹅。
没有活物敢过去。
两个人在城的两端，好吧，所以第25个节拍发钱，然后把老百姓全都发给了钱。
然后。
第26拍，黄四郎出招，黄四郎干什么呢？黄四郎派马车，所谓草船借箭，让老百姓把钱又都还了回来。
让老百姓把钱油都还了回来。所谓的草船借箭嘛。
所谓的草船借箭嘛，你看用马车啊，让老百姓把钱也都还了回来。
然后第二期第二7拍。
主角团队干什么呢？扎麻子干什么呢？发枪。
发枪。
发了枪，但是怎么回事呢？
没有人敢拿啊，发了枪没有人敢拿。第27拍发了枪，没有人敢拿。
然后第二8节块。
28拍第二天，大家趁晚上把枪都拿走了哎。
张麻子心里有底了。张麻子心里有底了。
然后第29拍，黄四郎继续如法如法炮制。
又派出马车草船借箭回收这些枪。
但是在回收枪的过程中呢，张麻子放了一个暗枪。
呼应了开头，让子弹飞打马车那个戏。
把它给破坏了，把它给破坏了，然后让他回收枪的计划失败。
这是第29part。
回收枪计划失败之后，张麻子心里彻底有底了。第三十拍第三0拍张麻子四个人就开始遛把。
骑着马尾的乘串喊口号发动群众。
然后呢，发老百姓逐渐动心，虽然没有采取行动，但是趴在门口开始看了，老百姓开始动心了。
然后张麻子呢打烂了皇家的铁门，给自己造势，这是第三0。
31盘。
31拍呢张麻子使出了最后的大招。
他手里不是有一个那个谁吗？
招麻子使出最后的大招是什么？
狸猫换太子呀。
他手里不是有黄马呃那个那个黄四郎的替身吗？记不记得之前有一个伏笔，他让女一号看着黄四郎的替身，记不记得啊？
他这时候拿出了黄四郎的替身。
然后斩首黄四郎。
让群众彻底沸腾。
然后鼓动群众去碉楼里面抢东西，说里面就是你们自己的东西，你们去拿回来吧。
这是第三期一拍。
3二拍。
张麻子彻底胜利了。
送别黄四郎对吧？见到了黄四郎啊，见到了黄四郎，然后给了黄四郎最后的体面。
你是个体面人，对吧？给了黄四郎最后的体面。
本质上本质上他跟虎王四郎倒是没有。
那么啊就是你死我亡的恨。
给了黄四郎最后的体面，这是第3二拍。
33拍33拍故事的最后一拍。
张麻子告别了他的兄弟们啊，他的兄弟们这个这个呃骑着自行车，拐着拐着女一号，对吧？都离开他了，要去上海啊，要去上海发展。
然后呢，张麻子在犹豫了呃，张麻子继续骑着马，在犹豫了一下之后呢，也跟着列车啊往这个上海的方向。
跟着去了。
以33拍啊，这就是故事的33个节拍啊，大家注意一下啊，最后一个开场是呃，最后一场戏是什么？
最后一场戏又是什么？
最后一场戏。
又是马拉列车，对不是？
看一下故事的第一场戏。
唉，你看这个很优秀的同学啊，回到原点啊，回到原点，似而不是啊，画面回到原点，似而不是啊。
这就是。
咱们的故事节拍。
故事节拍说完了啊。
故事的信息节拍说完了，我们来探讨几个问题。
先探讨创作上的问题吧，来同学们。
你们有没有想过哎，故事节拍啊是商业篇逻辑，对吧？我们课上讲故事节拍的时候，有些同学啊虽然嘴上没说，但内心肯定会暗暗的想，老师啊这样写会不会太降气了？
严格的按照节拍去卡会不会太降气了呀？
有些同学一定这样想。
但是我们看你说姜文老师这么有才华的人，这么桀骜不驯的人，这么不屑于套路的人。
他的故事为什么也基本上符合商业片的节拍逻辑呢？
为什。
就是因为。
中的审美呀。
是一样的。
中的基本审美它是一样。
即便是姜文老师这种大师，他不是啊他不像咱们这种编剧啊，咱们年轻的初学者，咱们在写故事的时候啊，我们内心是装着节拍的。所以呢在写到这儿的时候啊，我们会刻意的去卡终点，卡拐点，是吧？
直接拍。
但是像这种大师，他一旦要拍一个让观众过瘾的片子的时候，他是不自觉的就会卡上的。因为这是他的本能。
这是他的本能，你知道吧？这是基本逻辑，这是宇宙运行的规律。
而且这部片子咱们。
记得12年吧，应该是1213年上映的时候，姜文文老师自己说的呀，说我这一次就要拍一个大伤业片，拍一个看起来贼过瘾的片子，让你们知道知道，对吧？让你们看一看，让你们过个瘾。虽然我自己不喜欢，但是我可以拍一个这样的片子，让你们看一看。
所以你看姜文老师他也是懂套路。
就好像在课上曾经多次讲过这个周星驰老师，他的片子为什么好？
他就是按套路来啊。
然后有同学提到鬼子来。
我也最喜欢鬼子来了。
这个作品里面。
没问呃肯定的。
但是你让子弹飞，它确实是最商业的一步啊，商业上最成功成功的一步，也是最能获得广大观众喜欢和过瘾的一部。
所以说刚才拉了故事节派啊，同学们基本上就了解了啊，基本上了解了人家的故事的基本结构，以及娇文老师是怎么玩的。
那么现在我们回到刚才我给大家提的这个问题。
一句话不事。
这个故事。
这个故事他的一句话故事是。
然后如果还有同学啊琢磨不出这个故事的一句话故事。这个这个电影的一句话故事，或者是说这个电影它的基本的。
基本创意，也就是他基本对抗是什么？
那我们再来回答一个问题，这部片子是什么类？
这片子是什么类着？
我在讲类型片的时候啊，同学们，我在讲类型片的时候啊，有很多同学，比如说我在讲类型片的时候，我讲到假身份这种类型的时候啊，有很多同学给我举例子说老师让子弹飞不就是标准的假身份。
让子弹飞含有假身份的元素。
没错。
但是假身份啊，我们说假身份啊，这种类型的电影。
假身份这种类型的电影啊。
不是这么玩呢。
这部电影是什么呢？这部电影是什么类型？
这部电影是标准的。
金腰毛有一种类型叫什么？
叫复仇。
这部电影是标准的复仇片。
虽然它里面包含甲。
但是他不是以假身份为主要结构的。
为什么？
讲几个讲几个。
我给大家讲。
讲假身份。
讲假身份和金羊毛的区别啊，来大家看一下。
有几个原因。
第一个原因，我们来看一下激密事件的位置。
这都没有人让我。
哦。
哎。
他们讲的。
去留他们嗯。
要给我们鹅成一万，我们看一下。
激励事件的激励事件的位置。激励事件。我们说小六子死亡是激励事件，对不对？小六子被小六子被害了啊，小六子被害了，那激起我们主角团的目标就是报仇。
就是报酬。
我们说其实是不是有一个目标说要假利用假身份去搞钱啊？
确实有过这个目标，但那是什么位置？气概这是第一场。
这不是激励啊，第一场戏这是现状。
这是现状。所以说这个问题。
这是第一个线索啊这是第一个线索。我们来看第二个线索。
我们来看第二个线索。
第二个线索。
第二线索是什么呢？
就是如果以假身份为主要创意和主要对抗的话，那这个假身份的穿帮危机需要是递进的。穿帮之后带来的危害是要是要是灭顶之灾。而且这个穿帮是要放在灵魂黑夜的地方。
因为你最主要的对抗是假身份的话，那你假身份的穿帮的那一刻，就是你失去所有的那一刻，失去爱情的那一刻，失去亲情的那一刻，失去别人信任的那。
对不对？
我们回忆一下。
假身份的片子大家能想到什么？我给大家讲过的。
我给大家我就光我给大家讲过的片子就可以。大家想一想。
摇滚校园。
定制版了。
都是假身份。
我们说假身份穿帮的那一刻，就是这个主角啊陷入谷底的。
所以说。
这就是我们说的。
不是。
不是这个位置。
好吧。
然后第三个线索。
我们说所有假身份的片子。
在故事终点故事拐点那个位置。
是什么？
我们回忆一下。
这个这个定制伴郎。
定制伴郎在故事的中间啊，我们说的是中间的中，在终点之前，他要假扮你的好朋友。
在故事的终点之前，主角定制伴郎吗？假伴郎吗？我要假扮你的好朋友。
那在故事终点之后呢。
我要当你的真朋友。
再来看。
我们说嗯那个叫什么摇滚校园，在故事终点之前，我要什么？假装是一个老师。
假装是一个老师。
那在故事终点之后呢。
我要真的当一名老师，我要教小朋友。
所以同理，如果这个片子是以假身份为重要对抗。
那么在故事终点之前，我要假冒县长。
那在故事终点之后呢。
我要当一个真县长。
在这个故事里面显然不是。
是吧在这个故事里面。
我们的故事终点是什么位置啊？
故事终点是吧？是要。
就要搞死活死了是吧？本来是要搞他的钱，后来要搞死他是吧？所以说这个。
这个从从这几个情况啊。
就知道首先这部片子啊。
不是以假身份为主要对抗的。哎，这就给我们同学啊提一个想，不是说你的片子里面有假身份，你的假身份就是主要对抗。
并不是啊，但是啊再跟同学们透露一下。
这个故事的最早的版本肯定是以假。
因为假身份是这个故事原本的故事盒。
只不过后来写着写着呢，觉得只有一个假身份啊不过瘾啊，才把故事主线又推成了报仇。
这个同学们要理解人家的创作过程。
这个故事在创意的时候啊，实际上啊实际上确实是以假身份为起点的。
确是以假醛为题。
但是目前呢现在的结构它是一个标准的复仇片啊，激利事件是小六子的死，然后呢，主角要为小六子的死报仇，然后报仇呢报出了好几个层面啊，报仇报报出了好几个层面。
这是一个标准的。
复仇片啊，标准的复仇篇。
有同学说这是不是超级英雄，这不是啊，咱们不能因为咱们不能因为呃姜文导演他个人很雄壮啊，很有武力值，就认为这是一个超级英雄啊，这两码事啊两码事，而是一个非常标准的复仇片，而且有多层次的复仇。那么我们回到我们回到啊。
回到这个故事的。
故事创意或者是说一句话故事，那就非常明显了。
我们说。
假身份是他的现状，所以不是他的主要对抗。那这个那这个故事的故事创意，或者是说一句话故事应该怎么总结呢？一个什么样的人在什么情况下想要干啥？
一个什么样的人在什么情况下想要干啥？
同学们都非常明确了。
一个假冒县长捞钱的马匪，这是人设啊。我们说假身份是他固有人设，捞钱是他起始目标。我们说一个人设，我讲过人设，来，同学们给我回忆一下人设有什么。
身份缺陷境遇目标行动呀。
人设包含5个方面来，大家再记一下啊，人设包含5个方面身份缺陷境遇目标行动。
他的身份是什么马匪。
缺陷是什么？假县长对吧？目标是什么捞钱。
一个假冒县长捞钱的马匪。
在。
干儿子被害死以后。
决定。
为干儿子花式报仇。
实际上你可以理解为就是花式报酬。
因为他折磨这个黄四郎啊，折磨了好几个层次。
啊，折磨了好几个层次，对吧？因为他开始想搞他的钱，后来想搞他的命，最后还想杀人诛心，对吧？有好几个层次啊，花失报仇。
所以说是一个假冒现场捞钱的马匪。
啊，在干儿子被人搞死以后呢，决定为干儿子啊花失报仇，这就是这个故事的故事创意。
咱们将咱们刚才讲到。
花式报仇，为什么说是花式报酬？大家给我想一下这个故事的AB故事，来给大家几分钟想一下这个故事的AB故事。咱们不管是免费课还是训练营里面同学，我都讲过AB故事，对吧？
同学们给我想一下这个故事的APB故事。
联想一下，我给大家讲过拉过以前的片子的AB故事，给我想一下这个故事的AB故事。
想一下这个片子的AB故事，待会儿我揭晓答案。
哎，咱们咱们今天的直播啊，同学们在咱们今天直播，咱们今天虽然是关门直播，但也是直播啊。所以说在咱们直播间的同学还是可以报名咱们的编剧训练营。咱们今年的编剧训练营有30次直播拉片啊，除了这一次啊，除了这一次有30部片子的直播拉片，是咱们今年编剧训练营的一个。
特色啊一个增相。
除了过去的80多个课时以外，增加了34个拉片，帮助大家学习。咱们今年啊咱们今年这个编剧课啊呃。
2023年的招生刚刚开始啊，所以说。
希望大家如果想进入这个行业，抓紧报名。我也说了啊，2023年是这个影视的一个大年，开年啊，我跟你说。
不光是你们肉眼见到的，出了很多大票房，出了很多爆款。
实际上更重要的是什么啊？
实际上更重要的是今年。
发了很多许可证，呃，咱们直播间里肯定有咱们直播间里肯定有行业内的同学啊，大家应该知道呃，前几年这个。
备案呀、审批呀都很困难。
今年啊一开年就发了好多好多的字儿啊。
所以说这个。
大家这个。
呃。
今年进入这个行业是个非常好的时机，为啥呢？因为前几年啊影视公司倒闭了好多。
了好多之后呢有有有很多行业缺口，然后今年突然井喷了之后呢，人有点用不过来。我们今年有好多项目啊都启用的是新人编剧。
因为咱们的个课程啊咱们课程有个特点，因为咱们课程啊是个大IP啊，咱们查理的编剧课是行业内最大的编剧课啊，流量最大的学生最多的也是知名度最高的。
然后呢，所以说不光是跟咱们学编剧的同学多，找咱们写剧本的甲方也多啊，因为他会联系我们，因为甲方也听咱的课呀。
所以他会联系我们定制剧本。所以说在咱们这个编剧课里面，我们有个最大的优势，就是可以给大家提供投稿通道。
么官方的图片通道，你相当于你在我们这儿学会了写剧本，就进入了我们的编剧库啊，然后呢就可以呃参与咱们的征。
会不定时的到咱们来这儿来征稿，而且征稿的形式也多种多样啊。你像有有有有电影，还有网络电影，还有剧，然后还有短剧。另外去年还有呃几百个脱口秀的稿子，也是从咱们这儿出的，还有脱口秀里面的那种短剧小喜剧sketch。
很多这个咱们很多新人同学从这个入手呢就很友好。因为这个相对来说啊篇幅没那么长，相对来说好驾驭。
从这个角度去入手也蛮好的。呃，咱们今年有30部电影的拉片，都会像今天这样去详细探讨一个片子啊，详细了解一个片子的他人家的整个的创作过程啊，以及里面值得我们学习的地方。我们刚才探讨到了这个。
故事的AB故事啊，这个让子弹飞的AB故事来，同学们现在有这个这个。
大家有答案了吗？AB故事。
我们来回忆一下AA故事。
A故事我们讲的是什么啊？讲先回顾一下概念啊。A故事我们通常讲的是主角的行动线，对不对？
张麻子。
在行动线上明面的行动线上是是什么？
A故事是什么？
不是搞钱，怎么又回到搞钱了？搞钱是起始目标。A故事是它主行动线。
主行动线特别简单，给儿子报仇。
来，同学们，主行动现在是给儿子报仇，我们先把答案公布出来。
主行动线是给小六子报仇，这就是主行动线给自己的儿子报仇。
同学们回忆一下我课上。
我讲AB故事是对应关系，对吧？AB故事是对应关系呀。
我们讲一个想要殉职的警察，A护士是给自己的女儿报仇，保护自己的女儿。B护士呢？
屁不知他。
保护天下人的女儿啊。
那这里A故事和B故事不也非常明确了吗？A故事是什么？
给自己的儿子报仇。
B故司呢？
同时呢？
给天下苍生报仇呀，给黎民百姓报仇呀。
对不对啊？
在让子弹飞当中，AB故事的是非常明确的啊，A故事是给自己的儿子报仇，B故事是给黎民百姓报仇啊，在这里看一下一个重要的重要的一场戏。我刚才给你们看过，我让你们自己仔细看，我们来再来回头看一下。
再来回头看一下啊。
同学们再来看一场戏。
看一下这场气刘迪。
我发誓替你报仇。
先仔细看一下这哪些啊。
喝醉了。
法师替你报仇。
当个法师替你报仇。
放气了。
可不想让大伙拼命，命都不平还做。
应该听。
留言。
黄四郎这招叫杀人不用刀。
我给你爹出的招就杀人诛心。
不能拼命。
拼命还怎么挣钱呢？
溜子。
整钱对咱算个事儿。
我不是要杀安诛心，是没想出好办法。
我要把黄四郎掩格洞。
同学们告诉我这一场有什么特点？你看已经有聪明的同学说了啊，炮低四度墙。
对不对？
这场戏有个什么样诡异的地方呢？
同学们，这场是有个什么最大的最诡异的地方呢？
演员怎么剧中的角色，怎么可以盯着屏幕，怎么可以看观众呢？
狱中的角色怎么可以看观众呢？你看电影的时候有这种情况吗？
很少的。
很少有剧中的角色看着观众的时候呀。
对不对呀？
明白了吧？
他要给谁报仇啊？
你们都我们都是小六子啊。
明白这个意思吧？所以说这个故事啊当时才会引起那么多的讨论，甚至引起了很多过度的。
对吧因为他在这场戏里面，他打破了低俗路长，他盯着观众来说话。我们说角色跟观众是要有距离的，角色是戏中的角色，他一旦看着观众就破除了这个破除了这个这个这个界限了呀，这就没有边界感了呀，对不对？你这个剧中的角色你怎么能看我。
没有边界感了呀。
但是他就是要这么做，我们记得我们还拉过一个片子，我给你们拉过一个片子，最后一个镜头，经典镜头宋浩浩也盯着盯着观众看是什么给我打在评论里来。
宋康浩盯着观众看的那个片子是什么？
来同学们来宋康浩在结尾的时候盯着观众看的那个镜头，那个电影叫什么？我带着你们看过的。
对吧？
哦，那词不能打是吧？
回忆啊。
三人会议。
明白你现在明白了吗？
同学们现在明白这场戏什么意思了吗？
这也是为什么啊，所以说咱啊啊不不能打就不要打了，不能打就不要打了啊。
所以说同学们。
虽然我在刚开始讲的时候啊，我也说过啊。
不要对。
哎，这个这个一些影片啊，它里面的各种元素啊，有一个过度的解读啊，不要有个过度的解读，老琢磨创作者是要隐喻什么，按照什么心。
但是有时候啊你说这个事儿他也不能怪观众，你他妈自己拍这么一场戏。
你自己拍这么一场，盯着观众看的戏，意思就是我要给大家报仇啊，我要给你报仇啊，小。
你这些观众最后去。
观众最后去解读，但你也不能怪观众吧？所以说这场戏啊。
典型的啊典型的是。
典型的是一个啊告诉观众啊，我不是说只为小六度报仇啊，我不是。
但是我们说啊。
我接着说啊我接着说这个APB故事。
飞呀。
是少有的华语电影里面。
评分奇高的一种类型。
那你说这种片子如果只是中规中矩的是。
A故事是给自己的儿子报酬。
毕股时事给黎民百姓报仇。同学们，我课上讲过AB股时这平行对应啊，给自己的儿子报仇给。
别人的儿子报仇，或者是给天下人的儿子报仇，对吧？给天下子民报仇嘛？天下子民不就是儿子嘛？给天下子民报仇。
我们说这个对应关系，这个对账关系虽然工整。
虽然工整，虽然没错。
但是不是就略微显得有一些平庸呢？
如果是。
A护士是给自己的儿子报仇。
B故事是给别人的儿子报仇。那跟咱们课上讲的一个想要殉职的警察，那水平不也差不多吗？
对不对？
我们说。
定制伴郎A故事是假装你的好朋友。
地故事是什么？
成为你的真朋友，对吧？哎，假装你的好朋友成为你的真朋友。
定制八郎的。
AB故事，但是我们说定制霸郎豆瓣只值七点几分啊，是吧？摇滚校园呢假装一个老师A故事，B故事呢成为一个真老师AB故事。
让子弹飞。
A故事。
给自己的儿子报仇，庇护士给天下的儿子报仇。
是不是略微不是姜文老师的水平呢？
老师怎么能止步于此呢？
同学们。
这个故事啊。
还扒了一个层次，还扒了一层。
这个故事啊，如果从AB故事的角度啊，实际它还有C故事。
ABC故事。
A故事呢就关于为什么我们同学们，我前面说花式报酬。
同学们记不记得我在讲一句话故事的时候，我说这个电影讲的是一个想要捞钱的假县长，一个想要捞钱的假县长啊，然后呢自己儿子被人搞死以后。
给儿子花式报酬。
花式报酬，那就不能只有一分啊。
积分是什么？
给自己的儿子报仇。
B护是是呢？给黎民百姓报仇，或者是给天下子民报仇。C护士呢？
教天下子民报仇。
交天下之名报仇。
最后黄四郎不是他杀的。
最后黄四郎他是非要那些。
平民百姓冲进去杀。
为什么？
因为一个黄四郎倒下了。
还有千千万万的黄色。
黄四郎，你杀不干净的呀。
而且你如果自己冲进去杀了黄四郎，占领了他的碉堡。
那么。
屠龙者终成恶龙啊。
咱们说呀。
你自己就算不当恶龙，你的那些三弟四弟，他们也会成为恶龙的。
屠龙者忠诚恶龙。
所以说他。
A故事。
第一个层次是。
替儿子报仇。
第二个层次是替天下子民报仇。第三个层次是教天下子民反抗，教天下子民自己报仇。
因为屠龙者忠诚。
不想屠龙。
他甚至让黄四郎体面的走。
没有你对我很重要。
你死不死不重要。
对吧？
所以说你看这个层面，那你就知道他就不是个一般的商业片去搞的那个。我们说一般的商业片啊，后面如果你想要拍爽片，他就一定是张麻子进去把黄四郎杀了。
同学们啊，一般的商业片，如果我们要拍爽片，让观众看得过瘾，一定是张麻自进去把pos。
但是这里他不这么做。
他又花篇幅，我给你们切过去啊。
。
糟了走了。
我成起身了，去吊楼，拿回你们自己的东西。
啊呀。
可了。
这场戏大家明白了吧？
他是要教大家复仇啊，教大家复仇，这就是第三个层面啊第三个层面。
能理解吗？
能理解这个三个层面吗？以后啊知道啊这个。
有一些故事啊，他是不。
止步于AB股市啊不止步于AB股市。
第一个层面给自己的儿子报仇。
第二个层面，给天下子民报仇，天下子民不天下的儿子嘛？天下为公嘛，对吧？他是谁？
张牧之是谁？张麻子是谁？
啊。
革命军的啊这个是。
蔡了将军的这个是吧，护卫。
天下围攻。
对吧线下围攻。
所以说你看在这个故事里面啊，它的层级推的就比较多。那有些同学问，那我们写的时候要不要也这么写这么多层面呢？
装不下。
是吧装不下。
大部分时候啊，你的情节组织能力啊装不下这么多，对吧？
你正经事儿还没办完呢，就先别办这个事儿了。
这个呢就是游刃有余的导演啊，游刃有余的导演去往上推啊，游刃有余的导演他再推一个层次，相当于什么呢？相当于咱们都去这个参加举重，对吧？大家都能举出一个举起1个90公斤级。但是呢最后那几个人呢，人家总要是挑战一下世界纪录的。
再加两片杠铃，再来一下。
部分人啊第二第二次试举就可以了，对吧？你就别搞别搞那么别搞那么多了，实际没有必要，你也驾驭不了啊，你也驾驭不了。因为。
我们这么复盘啊，看起来是简单啊，你这么复盘，你用嘴巴巴在的扯淡。
当然了，他他妈看起来挺简单啊，但实际上你知道这个剧本的创作过程是有多么磨人嘛，对吧？他怎么他妈把这个故事塞在一起，他有多费劲，他有多少取舍，他有多少这个痛苦的历程嘛。
我跟你说，这个假身份最后被边缘化到，基本没有产生危机，就是为这些事情给让路了。
对吧如果叫我们写假身份这的一番，我们肯定要再发挥一下。
同学们啊，你你这么去回忆啊啊，这么去复盘啊，这个故事当时如果这个创意给到你，你这个假设判不可能这么轻飘飘放过去的。
肯定是比如说先被花姐给看到了，先让花姐识破，你不是真县长了，我们还要预防着花姐会不会告诉会不会告诉那个。
那个那个那个黄四郎呀，对吧？你要做几番层次的，懂这个意思吧？他是有取舍的同学们。
明白这个道理吧？
同学们啊，一定要明白这个道理啊，不要瞎来。
另外啊讲到这个复仇来。
我们说这个不宣子啊。
这部片子啊还有一个很重要的点。
一直在点题一直在点题叫杀人诛心。
杀人之心。
这个片子一直在点一个题叫杀人诛心。
同学们。
杀人诛心啊，往往他是这样啊，先杀人再诛心，为什么呢？因为肉体好消灭，但是灵魂难消灭啊，诛心难消。
但是这部片子啊人家搞了一个诛心，先诛心，对吧？先让你失去人心。
我在杀你。
先搞精神层面，再搞肉体层面。
我们说在大绝大部分商业片里面，我们先解决肉体问题，先解决实际问题，再解决精神问题。
对不对？
这个能听懂吗？这个略微有点不太好懂啊，同学们啊，在大部分的商业片篇里面，我们先解决肉体问题，再解决精神层面的问题。在大部分的商业片里面。
但是在高级的片子里面，在好的片子里面，在游刃有余的创作者那里，他有时候可以先搞精神层面，再搞这种题。
同学们，我在曾经给你们拉一个片子的时候，我给你们讲过那个片子就是先搞真精神，再搞肉体，然后那部片子获得了巨大的成。
回忆一下。
那部片子是什么？
来，我就看看有没有在一两年以前认真听。哎呀妈肖申课。哎呦，我的天哪，这两个学生让我这三个学生让我热泪盈眶啊。
四个5，哎呦，我的天哪。
怎么有这么多？
你们真的这么认真听讲吗？
你们真的这么认真，我拉片儿拉肖申克，你们都记得啊。
我的天哪。
这些是多么优秀的学生啊。
我真的有点感动了。
是一直跟着学习的同学吧。
天哪。
真的挺让人感动的啊。
同学们肖申克的救赎，大家回忆一下。
肖申克的救赎讲的就是一个被冤枉入狱的一个。
一个人。
一个一个一个安迪，对吧？他被判了。
这个这个很长的一个图形被被误误判杀妻。
但是呢他也认为他对他妻子不够好，他开始是觉得自己被冤枉的。后来虽然他没有杀他的妻子，但他觉得他间接杀了他的妻子，他对他妻子不够关心。
然后我们说肖申克的救赎AB故事是什么？
肖申克的A救赎AB故事是什么？
特别好找，对吧？我们说肖申克的救赎讲的是越狱的故事啊，他在监狱里他要越狱嘛？经最经典的越狱篇。那么A故事当然是越狱了，追寻肉体的自由。
追寻肉体的自由。
A护事。
因为它的主线故事是越狱，显象的行动现是越狱，所以A故事叫做追求肉体的自由。那么你告诉我B故事是什么？
一不时是追求精神的自由嘛。
所以简单说，你看这同学说的非常对，A故师是越狱B巫师是。
救赎不就是追求精神上的自由吗？因为他觉得我有罪呀，我有罪呀。
我追求灵魂的己。
但是你看肖申科的救赎，他就先追求精神，我先赎罪。
我精神上自由了。
我在这个监狱里面精神上彻底自由了，那我现在要出去了。
笑。
好看。
过瘾。
你在没有学我的课程之前啊，你就是单纯的觉得真。
真扎心也真过瘾，真好看。但是你不知道为什。
让子弹飞也是这样。
他反复强调，杀人诛心，杀人诛心。
先诛心再杀。
先消灭了你的肉体，没有意思。
所以在。
鸿门宴那场戏第二幕第一场戏鸿门宴。
我都带人进去了。
没意思。
杀他的肉体没意思。
陷他的杀他的精神。
先山他杀他的精神。
再杀他的同类。什么叫同类啊？我就是让。
老百我教老百姓报酬，确保以后不会再出现这样。
我先杀他的精神，再杀他的同类。最后他的肉体杀不杀两可啊，自己处理吧。
给你一种给你一个体验。
自己处理。
明白吗？
明白这个片子为什么让你从精神层面有一定的享受，甚至忍不住想去解读一下。
忍不住想去，哎呀，这个马。
代表了什？
代表表一种什么主义呢？为什么第一个镜头列车往左走，第二个镜头往右走，到底代表了我。
一种选择呢，对吧？为什么汤师爷牵大马回来的时候戴着两顶帽子呢？对吧？这么两个帽子又代表了什么呢？
天天就在家研究这些东西。
必要那些是表象的东西啊，那些反而是表象的东西。而且啊我再跟大家说一个。
故事呃说一个。
呃，说一个关于这个电影解读暗喻的，我们有很多同学啊忍不住解读电影的暗喻啊。
在这里我跟大家说一下。
待遇这个事情啊是这样，你只要看到一个巧合。
你就会发现。
其他的都能自动匹配上。
所以说暗玉绝大部分并不是创作者。
出发点。
他就是你的。
一个想法。
他就是你的一个。
戒毒。
你明白我的意思吧？
就是。
待遇这种东西啊，是你自己催眠你自己的。你往往是就是你发现了一个巧合。比如说同学们发现我今天穿着一件绿衣服坐在一个红椅子身上，对吧？大家觉得哇，那红与绿老是应该就是代表了比如说某两个国家目前的一个战争是吧？某俄国战争。
然后呢发现老老师啊在今天讲课的过程中啊，只往后靠了三次，分别是什么时间节点？然后这三个时间节点代表了三次和谈的机会。在大部分情况下，老师都是虽然坐着椅子，但是不愿意靠在靠背上，这不就是证明了目前这两个国家的关系吗？
曾经是兄弟，现在怎么怎么着。
你你真的你全都能网上。
你全都能对上。
要是愿意这么去解读，你全都都对上。
但是没有这个必要。
没有这个必要啊。
啊，有同学问，那是不是不应该设计隐喻，就不要设计隐喻，根本就没有必要设计隐喻。有很多同学啊，你你上过我的课，你就知道啊，咱们编剧啊，以咱们的主要目标就是创作一个精彩的故事，而不是给观众上课，甚至还给观众捉迷藏，让他找出隐喻，觉得你牛逼，又学到了东西。
听听郭德纲老师的话吧，你先弄一个好的节目再说吧，不要老想着给别人当老师，不要老想着给别人弄点比喻教育一下别人。所以大家都不要去把精力放在这件事情上，好不好？所有上我课的同学都听老师一句话。
你做一个行业，你做影视行业，就是为了服务观众，就是为了给观众拍一个好看的片子过瘾的片子，让观众过过瘾，而不是给他上上课。
郭德纲老师，人家那么大的学问，那么大的本事，人家都反复在强调这件事情，可别给观众上课了，别拿自己当回事儿。
不要去设计这些所谓的隐喻，你你你你想表达什么？
对吧你就想让别人觉得你牛逼呗，没有用啊没有用，就是把故事写的精彩是最好的，好不好？
说到故事精彩，我们再分析点最基础的。
关注心理学。
我们说这个故事除了ABC3个层面，除了小六的复仇。
这么具这么具有代表性的事情，除了三个主角的设定，对吧？我们说。
张麻子、康师爷、黄四郎这三个人物啊这三个人物啊，同学们啊。
招麻子。
汤师爷、黄四郎这三个人物。
我们说这三个人物我在课上讲过。
主角和。
对手是什么？
主角和对手是什么？
主角和对手是。
一朵枝头的两朵是一个是一个枝头的两朵花呀。
主角和对手是一个枝头的两朵。
他们师出本同门啊，师出同门奈何相煎啊？
一起两面。对。
咱们这个故事里面有三个角色，是双生花呀。
三个角色呀。
康师也。
张麻子。
黄四郎。
这三个人都是镜像的呀，同学们。
苍师爷、黄四郎、张麻子这三个人都是同样的人，他们三个人都参加过革命。
他们三个人。
都曾经留洋。
他们都接受过西方的教育。
他们都在民国时期，北洋时期。
不过三个人在暂时的失败之后，走上了三条不同的路。
三个人都懂洋文啊，在北洋时期，三个人可都懂日文，懂洋文啊。
三个人一看都是留学东阳的。
明白这个意思吗？
他们三个人可都是留学东。
都曾经跟随一个跟随蔡一个将军，一个跟随刘都统。
他们可曾经都是时代的弄潮。
从这个角度，你发现这种片子它多商业啊。
我跟你们讲过啊，主角和对手是两生花。
镜像的啊镜像的。
这里三个角色。
那我们再来看一下啊，在这样一部片子里面，在这样一个片子。
他从观众心理观影的角度。
这部片子啊我们说它有个特点啊，他老少嫌宜，就喜欢深度的那些同学啊，哎能看出深度，喜欢文艺的同学呢又感觉里面有很多文艺的调调啊这配乐呀，这韵镜啊。
然后呢，喜欢热闹的同学呢又觉得这个片子很商业啊，热热闹闹打打闹闹的也很好看。
那同学们来我们就来分析一下它的商业元素。
我们说从商业的角。
这部片子他从观众观影心理学的。
他又达到了哪些层面的满？
我们说观众心理学基素层级的基素层级。
观众心理学来训练营的同学来给我回答一下基素层级的三个满足是什么？
打不出字儿来就用别的代替啊，打不出字儿来用拼音代替拼音代替基素成级的前三个满足是什么？
观影心理学里面激素层级的前三个。
前三个满足是什么？
是吧。
性暴力喜剧。
这个电影前三个元素是不是？
我们说男男女荷尔蒙。
拉满。
暴力拉嘛，我们说这部戏啊暴力是第一第一标签。
各种骑马各种装备展示。我们说马是暴力的啊，是列车是暴力的。
然后。
各种装备啊各种马靴、肌肉。
都拉满。
然后同时这部片子非常明确的喜剧元素。
前三个全给你拉满。
前三个元素全被你拉满。
我们说。
吸引一个观众在激素层面一共有三个元素，性暴力喜剧全部拉满。
那我们回到大脑皮层呢。
层我们说有若干的满足。
但是呢我他写在前面的也往往是。
比较重要的满足层级呢也是比较高的。第一个是什么？
第一个是什么？
同学们。
脑皮层满足排第一的是什么？或者是卡在脑皮层满足卡在激素满足最下面的是什么？不是新知识。
振饭。
是报仇雪恨，伸张正义啊。
是报仇雪恨和伸张正义。
在第一个是报仇血恨和伸张正义啊。
对不对？是振奋呀。
报仇雪恨，伸张正义，是不是这部片子最重要的东西？
所以说从这个层面啊，这部片子的商业元素是。
这部片子的商业元元素啊是拉满。
振奋是两者中间的嘛，因为它仅次于脑皮层呀。
仅次于激素级和脑皮层，仅次于激素级啊，卡在激素肌和脑皮脑皮层中间嘛，报仇血恨肾张。
是不是重大满足啊？
当然这个知识可能。
只在训练营讲过啊，这个知识可能只在训练营讲。
有同学问金钱属于啥？金钱属于暴力啊，你好好听课，我应该讲过的啊，金钱属于暴力。
暴力不值不是值。同学们啊，你如果上过训练营，你知道啊？暴力片不是值不仅仅是指枪战呀或者动作啊，不仅仅是指枪战和动作。我们说一切能延展你身体的都属于暴力，对吧？一切能延展你身体的都是暴力。我们说车子是腿的延伸。
速度与激情就是暴力片啊，在美国就定位定位成那个18岁以上观看的。
因为开车啊是属于暴力啊属于暴力。
金钱可太暴力了。
金钱可太暴力啦。
哎呀，同学们说这个这个呃同学们想要报名今年这个呃2023训练营的啊，要抓紧时间。因为咱们今年啊会有30次这样的直播拉片啊，呃然后选片子呢一是选呃确实要选一些好好看的，能学到东西的。第二呢就是平常平常呢大家也会投票。
到底想看什么片子？这个让子弹飞呢，就是之前同学们投票投出来吧啊。
啊，然后大家很喜欢这个片子，所以说坚持让我给大家讲一讲。其实这部片子啊外面解读的人很多啊，外面解读的人特别多，特别喜欢解读里面的隐喻啊，这三个人并排站是什么意思呀？为什么他站左边，他往右看了一眼？
就特别喜欢解读这种东西，咱们不搞这种玄学啊，咱们不搞玄学，咱们就学知识，咱们就学怎么写，怎么创意。你像这个电影它的创意过程，我可以给大家完全的复盘一下。就是首先发现有一个小说，这个小说里面呢有一个有一个主线叫一个马匪啊，假扮县长。
去上任。哎，你看这个创意就很好，所以呢就借着这个主线去写。
就借着这个主线去写啊，一个马匪，哎，捡到一个委任状，正好民国的时候的时候，哎，正好当时委论县长很混乱，大家都是去捞钱的。所以一个马匪捡到一个伟人状啊，他就要去他抢到一个伪人状，他就要去当一个县长。然后呢，因此闹出了很多乌龙，对吧？因为他毕竟是个假县长，他是个马匪啊，但是呢虽然他是个假县长，是个闹出乌龙。
但是他是个正义的人。
他是个正，他最起码是个直肠子呀，他还会比那些恶毒的县长还干得好呢，你别看他是个。
所以说你看这个故事啊，它原本就是一个标准的假乡分的故事。但是在写着写的过程中呢，大家不断的创作，不断的碰撞，对吧？七八十几个编剧，十几个编剧啊，当时真的是。
就来碰撞这个故事，最后呢就碰撞成这样一个商业结构，非常的呃这个这个情节非常的。
他非常的左手，一场戏啊交待七八个信息。有时候所以说最后这个故事啊他就搞出来了，他就搞的是成熟了这样一个故事。我们要了解这个过程，千万不要以为啊千万不要以为人家从设计之初。
就是搞了这么多隐喻。
呼唤了那么多时代，甚至有的哎要把这个片子吹的都都玄乎了。实际上咱们要说在姜文老师的作品里面，这部电影并不是最。
触类把萃的啊，并不是最粗类把萃的，它只是最商业的啊最商业的。
但实际上从结构上来。
我我认为他都不算是最商业的，它只是商业上最成功的。从结构上来看啊，其实还是说鬼子来了要比这。
我就说看完。
呃，听完今天的拉片课，同学们可以回去看一看。
那部片子啊，但是可能得花时间找一找。
可能得花时间找一找。
知道我上的哪部片子啊，这个这个嗯那部片子比这个片子要要。
要出色一些啊，咱说实话比要出色一些嗯。
训练营会拉的片子有两种。第一种呢就是我认为我选出来的，我认为对大家有帮助的那些非常好的片子，大家去一起去拉一起去欣赏。还有一种呢是同学们呼声比较高的。因为一方面是我的咱们教育学啊。
同学们教学是双向奔赴的啊，一方面我有我的观点。另外一方面呢，你们也有你们的诉求，咱们双向奔赴，我选一部分，你们选一部。
所以说训练营的拉片是这么定的啊，但是你不要着急啊，你不要着急，你报名训练营的同学先把课看一看啊，先把课看的差不多，我们才能开始拉。
你啥知识还都没看，我给你拉也白拉。
比如说咱们今天有些同学可能跑进来了，就来听个热闹，对吧？他听的感觉也挺热闹的，觉得有些地方有点意思，也有点也好像说的也对。但是呢对于他实际创作啊可能帮助没那么大，因为他没有在写，你知道吗？
所以说还是真正在写的那部分同学才能理解我在说什么，才能理解我为什么说AB故事之后还有一个C故事，你马上就get到那个点了。因为你写的时候啊，你也会遇到这样的问题。
所以同学们啊教学这个东西啊，一定是个双向奔赴。我们网络课程啊，它就更是这样，对吧？我们线上的课程虽然线上课程有它的优势，就是性价比很高，很便宜。你平常日常生活中，你找我这样的老师，你找不到，对吧？在你们县里，在你们市里，你找不到我这样的老师，能找到，即便能找到我，那也太贵了。
但是线上课程啊它性价比高，而且你报名之后，你可以看一辈子这个课程。
你永远可以看对吧？性价比比较高，但是缺陷是什么？缺陷就是我们之间啊沟通太少，因为不在对面嘛，所以我们要加强沟通，双向奔赴教学相长，你们有什么诉求表达给我，我就给你们讲好不好？咱们今天啊咱们今天给大家拉片的是。
让子弹飞。
同学们要学到啊，我们复盘一下，除了我给大家讲了一下信息节拍以外，同学们要知道啊，这部片子是一个金羊毛类型的片子，为什么呢？它是目标导向型啊，目标导向型，因为它的激励事件是最重要的，激励事件是什么？死人了，所以它的目标是报仇。
的目标是报酬，然后报酬呢他报了三个层次，第一个层次呢是。
给我的儿子报仇。第二层次呢是给天下子民报仇啊，给别人的儿子了，就相当于是给自己的儿子报仇，给别人的儿子报仇。你看啊这就是A故事和B故事。最后呢，他最后他自己还是没有报仇，他延展到了C故事，就是教天下子民报仇，为什么呢？因为你只能杀掉一个黄四郎。
抱你的丝仇而已，天底下有无数个黄四郎，而且这里杀掉一个黄四郎，马上会出现一个新的黄四狼，屠龙者忠成恶龙，你不当黄四郎，你的那些兄弟也会当的呀，对不对？你如果不管这个事情，我跟你说，下一个黄四郎就是那个五五五五武状元嘛，他一定会会成为武状五状元的呀。
好不好？
所以说同学们要了解这个事情啊，然后这个故事创意我们的一句话故事是什么呢？就是一个假冒现场捞钱的马匪，一个什么人是吧？这个人包含他的环境，他的缺陷，他的技能，他的缺陷啊，他的缺陷，他的技能，他的目标对吧？一个假装现长捞钱的马匪，然后遇到了一个什么样的突发的situation呢？
我们说情况啊，境遇situation一个角色遇到一个什么situation呢？儿子让人搞死了，本来是来捞钱的，开开心心的假冒县长捞钱的马匪。儿子让人搞死了situation，然后他现在决定干什么决定花式复仇，这么死这个黄四狼弄死鸭的，对吧？他不就是这么一个流程吗？一个什么样的人？
一个什么样的情况，他想要干啥？
明白这个道理吧？
然后这节课我们还学到了什么？还学到了人家决策设定呀，最重要的三个决策为什么能出台？我们说最重要的三个决策为什么不能出台？
张麻子。
黄四郎康世演，我说他三个人啊，本是同根生呀。
本是同人生呀，同样的角色，面对不同的遭遇，选择了不同的路。我们说本质上啊本质上在电影里面或者是在现实主义题材电影里面不主装写大恶大善之人。
不主张写完美人格和十恶不赦的人，为什么嘞？没有那样的人呀？主角张麻虎他虽然是个好人，但是他也劫道啊，他也杀人呀，他也抢钱呀。你们你他杀的那些人是坏人吗？
他上来就就掀翻了列车，杀了那么多人，那些人不也就是普通的打工仔嘛，对吧？给给县场开开车的打工仔。
然后呢，进了城呃，然后最后卡了那个。
那个那个那个黄四郎的替身，我们说黄四郎的替身说实话不也是个苦命人吗，对不对？
这个理论上是吧。
所以说你看主角啊，他也并不是一个完人，对吧？他本来也是打算来捞钱的，甚至呢他在完全没有了解人康师爷的人品的情况下，对吧？就把人媳妇给睡了，是吧？也不太好。咱说实话。
克制。然后呢。
这个这个坏人呢，我们说黄四郎他也是给刘督统办事的一个人嘛，他早年也是参加革命，想要振兴北洋的嘛，明白这意思吧？所以说大家都是同一个枝头上开出的花朵而已，不同的境遇，你看这就是主角团的魅力。
我们说这几个角色啊是主要角色，它有魅力啊它有魅力。
但是。
我们说你看其他角色。
就全都是MP。
我们说除了这三个人啊，其他角色全都是NPC包括所有的女一号花姐，对吧？包括他的那些亲兄弟，老二老三老四戏份比较中的，你像老三不要。
都是MPC啊，为啥从头到尾啊没有什么。
被抗啊，而且也不是。
他们真的就是零件啊，就是大家就是主角拆出来的一些小零件而已。好吧，这就是你要理解人物创造到底哪几个人物是下功夫的，哪几个人物是赌上劲儿了。同学问陈坤的角色，那陈坤的角色那更是NPC了，虽然戏份很多，但他就是黄黄四郎的团队而已啊。我们说。
恶人啊是要有团队的啊，飞猴fly monkey对吧？飞猴。
团队啊这个他没有具体的那个呀他没有具体的以自己的那个诉求的呀。所以说这种角色啊虽然戏份挺多的啊，跑来跑去戏份挺多的，但是从我们角色创造上来说啊，实在是呃就是不是不是不根本跟那三个人没法比。
跟那三个人没法比。
从咱们角色创作啊，倾注的心血来说啊，跟那三个角色就没法比了。好吧，还有想要报名咱们今年训练营的同学，想要参与后面34拉片的同学啊，赶紧呃这个在评论里面说一下自己的诉求，没有的话，我要下播了，好吧。
那咱们今天的直播课差不多就这样了，咱们下次直播再见啊，咱们下次直播再见好。
拜拜。
第一步，搜索公众号查理的编剧课。第二步，点击关注公众号，第三步，点击右下方课程，查看课程详情，赶紧行动吧。